there actually are people listening in
as there usually are anyways
so welcome to our demise Thursday
research conference you probably have
some questions as what does Bill have to
do with blockchain with social
determinants of health you will find out
and I'm looking forward to giving this
talk to actually sharing with the
Department this activity I haven't I've
told some people bought it it's not a
secret or anything but you'll hear a
little bit more OHSU has been involved
in this basically business incubator
around for non-financial uses of
blockchain which I'm still trying to
figure out what they are but anyways and
and John has helped me so I will I've
been working with John Klaus I'll
introduce soon in a moment because OHSU
is a partner in this incubator and and
actually in John's first slide he'll
tell you a little bit more about it but
basically looking at some health
applications and the one company that
kind of emerged to step forward a
company called patient Ori so here a
little bit about is interested in in
tying social determinants of health data
to blockchain so so part of the purpose
of doing this is to share this with you
all there's a secondary motive and that
we actually submitted a presentation to
the hims conference in March that's been
accepted so we're presenting it there so
this is also gives us an opportunity to
do a little bit of a dry run and see
what we may need to add or subtract from
our slides and so being as verbose as
you all are you'll give us good ideas
positive and negative anyway so before I
start let me introduce John Klaus who
works for Moda health which
does have connections with though Hsu
although really neither of us are kind
of at the level of the sort of Moto Hsu
connections my main connection that OHSU
like most of you is that they administer
our health insurance but john has
nothing to do with that so don't
complain about those anyways but mota is
also a partner in the incubator and
you'll see kind of some of the ideas
that we have so John is a data scientist
at Moda and he has two master's degrees
from University of Washington and
information science and an MBA and so
I'm gonna turn it over so he's going to
talk a little bit about the incubator I
will kind of set the stage around social
determinants of health and then he'll
talk about blockchain and then at the
end we'll try to tie it together and
share with you some of the things that
we're hoping that might come out of this
incubator and there are some others who
are hopefully connected to the web
stream and are listening in and as
always our if anyone has any questions
outside of OHS you fire up a tweet and
put hashtag D mice comp diem IC e conf
on it and we'll follow the Twitter feed
to try to answer your questions so I
will actually not turn it over to John
thanks Bill so social determinants of
health and blockchain aren't necessarily
an obvious connection just to calibrate
on the room slide show of hands how many
people were primarily interested in the
social determinants of health components
okay and primarily interested in the
blockchain component okay
so we're we're weighted on the social
determinants of health side that's good
to calibrate on blockchain how many
people have have heard of cryptocurrency
or Bitcoin itself solid so and and then
separate from the idea of cryptocurrency
has anyone done reading or looked into
blockchain as an independent technology
okay so it's on well I'm hoping that in
addition to talking about the
introducing blockchain we can make the
case for a practical real-world example
which is actually pretty tricky outside
of the finance space so the the
conversation that bill and I have been
part of it joined up with the Oregon
enterprise venture block studio which
was a local firm our GA does some
consulting and some startup processes
for organizations and they were
interested in leveraging the potential
of technology in in in Oregon in
Portland in particular and trying to see
if there's something about blockchain
and the development expertise in state
that that we could harnessed to kind of
build a sort of ecosystem around in this
state bought into their proposal and
helped to bring together a consortium of
companies to look at these non-financial
uses for blockchain so I'm caught bank
OHSU Moda a number of other
organizations came together with experts
in the blockchain space so that's that's
where H su and Moda came in there's a
group called patient Ori out of Atlanta
that is in the population health space
so in between primary care and insures
the idea of trying to help with
population health and all of the
challenges involved in that around
integrating information and connecting
social services primary care specialty
and the the needs of an individual
patient that really are not a core
competency in some primary care
practices so patient Ori came to this
with the technology band with an
interest in blockchain and is we were
talking across the participants organ
about the opportunities the idea of
addressing the needs for collecting
information on social determinance of
health that span organizations and
healthcare boundaries rose to the top as
one of the most practical implications
so we spent a number of months going
back and forth putting together a case
that led
to drafting a paper it was the form the
limit of the presentation for hims and
we're at today so from here
bill talked about the social deterrence
of health and the context why these are
important and then we'll talk about
blockchain and how those fit together
okay so um I actually have to admit I'm
not the foremost expert on social
determinants of health and maybe there's
others in the audience who I could just
give this to and you can give my talk
but I as part of this project I've
become more familiar with it and of
course I'm well aware that social
determinants of health are probably more
well are more important to actually
people's health especially people who
are impacted adversely by social
determinants of health than what we do
in the healthcare system and so I think
one of the driving questions for this
project is are there technologies that
can help capture information about
social determinants of health that can
be used by the healthcare system or
others to attempt to ameliorate some of
those problems so so really I'm going to
talk about just some definitions for
those of you who are less familiar some
of the challenges around social
determinants of health and then
naturally there are some informatics
aspects to it that are important so it's
been estimated that that really only
about 20% of impact on people's health
actually comes from the healthcare
system I mean we're in the middle of a
big healthcare system here that's what
ossu does it provides healthcare it
trains healthcare professionals but I
probably don't need to convince anyone
that there are many other factors in
people's lives that impact their health
and this figure comes from the URL
listed here that just lists some of the
other factors that impact people's
health
such as behaviors diet smoking exercise
things like that social and economic
factors education employment income
family and social support and the
physical environment where people live
so people have challenges with housing
with nutrition and things like that that
adversely impacts their health and that
only the healthcare system can only do
so much for again probably something
that most of you know actually read
yesterday that that finally after
reversing a like five-year trend of life
expectancy going down it's ticked
slightly back up in the US but among
developed countries as you all probably
know life expectancy in the u.s. is
among the lowest and there's all sorts
of reasons for that our health care
system is certainly part of it but there
are many other factors income
disparities housing transportation and
so forth and there's this adage that you
know with apologies to the
bioinformaticians in the room you know
where the you know the genome is
supposed to be the determinant of your
how it is no question about it but
actually your zip code is a big
determinant of your health where you
live that indicates your likelihood of
employment of good housing and so forth
so to achieve all that all the great
things we can do with understanding more
about the genome some of these problems
need to be addressed as well so the
Kaiser Family Foundation has another
model of social determinants of health
most you're probably familiar with this
but all of these different factors lead
to health outcomes that people have and
sometimes the in our society the public
health view and approach to health can
be at odds with the medical approach so
this paper was it's a viewpoint that was
published in JAMA
several months ago they they noted that
the in Flint Michigan with the lead in
the pipes the that was actually
discovered by a clinician by physician
who noticed high levels of lead in
patients that were showing up at his
clinic and that led to investigation and
ultimately discovering the pipes so that
I mean that's a great public health
story but that's in contrast with and
actually see there's some EPC folks here
the US Preventive Services Task Force
guideline is equivocal about lead
screening and and at a population level
there might be some equivocations about
that but there are also some reasons
that it's really important to screen
certain populations for lead and so the
the public health approach is not
necessarily at odds but sometimes it
just prioritizes things different and we
need both and the public health approach
is probably better at managing social
determinants of health one way to talk
about it is a kind of upstream so the
public health system is upstream where
people are kind of starting to enter the
stream towards health problems and then
we're in the health care system we're
down here at the end of it downstream
when some of these problems treated
upstream could have lead could have
improved things and the healthcare
system doesn't do a particularly good
job of identifying social determinants
of health part of it is because
clinicians are really busy their patient
loads are increasing they have to spend
more time entering data into their EHRs
as we know and they don't always get the
opportunity to address social
determinants of health in fact this
study published last year found that
only 24% of hospitals and 16% of
physician practices were screening for a
wide range of social determinants of
health
and fortunately the rates were actually
higher among hospitals and physicians
who took care of patients who were more
likely to
have social determinants of health
influencing their health but still many
of these concerns don't get addressed
because of financial incentives busyness
and things like that in the health care
setting but there are opportunities and
and this paper that was also published
last year kind of provides a nice almost
use case and back when John ever gets
done talking about blockchain and kind
of tying these two things together we'll
actually talk about meals on wheels as a
potential organization there there could
be many others so what this study is
about you know most of you are familiar
with meals on wheels they go out they
deliver meals to people who don't have
the transportation or the finances to to
get meals on a regular basis and for the
most part meals on wheels goes and
delivers the meals but in this one
instance they actually trained the meals
on wheels staff as they went out to look
for things related to social
determinants of health and they
uncovered all kinds of problems health
problems things that were impeding
people from providing self-care mobility
home the rest of them are all listed
here and over a 12-month period the
drivers identified 429 alerts for 189
clients of meals on wheels and we'll
talk about one of the challenges is how
to get this data to the healthcare
system and to others who need it and
there's again there's a possible role
for blockchain here this is just a
diagram from that paper I won't go
through it but just kind of showing the
decision path that the Meals on Wheels
drivers used
another study done from our colleagues
in Indiana in Indianapolis of the famous
health information exchange that provide
they looked at an intervention where
they provided what they call wraparound
services in primary care so the primary
care system wasn't necessarily able to
provide these services but there was a
screening process to look for needs that
people had to refer people to
appropriate social services that could
help with some of the problems that were
identified and they actually were able
to show a some somewhat of a decrease in
hospitalizations and emergency
department visits so providing these
services provided value in terms of
reducing hospitalizations and emergency
department visits there are some
interesting challenges around social
determinants of health from an
informatics standpoint so for those of
us who think about various systems were
implementing or data that we're trying
to collect to do things with so to keep
these things in mind this is Exia the
first person to show me this slide was
Shannon McWeeny
because from her standpoint the
interesting part of this slide so this
is from a report by McKinsey the
consulting firm looking at the amount of
data that we generate in our lifetimes
and it turns out that that healthcare
data clinical data is actually really a
tiny piece when you think of all the
other information related to health that
gets generated about us on the order of
a petabyte so over a thousand terabytes
as opposed to clinical care a mere half
a terabyte and so so from an informatics
standpoint it's important because
there's a lot of data out there how do
we organize that data standardized and
I'll talk about that in a moment
maintain the veracity of it how do we
know who it belongs to
whether it's been tampered with things
like that and are one of the another
challenge related informatics is that
our health care system because it's not
well optimized for social determinants
of health also isn't well optimized to
collect data about it so for example can
we
code icd-10 codes to at least get that
part of social determinants of health
into the patient record and people have
looked at the different controlled
terminologies the ones that most of you
are familiar with lowing sno-med ICD and
identified gaps and while we're making
improvements in our ability to capture
structured data around social
determinants of health there are still
gaps in terms of what is covered what
one effort is actually looking at an
effect there's been these Z codes added
to icd-10-cm that can be used for the
clinical system any ways to add codified
data to do things like population level
statistics and so forth out of clinical
data hl7 the standards organization is
has a project called gravity that is
looking at building out the structured
data around social determinants of
health and I assume over time this will
get incorporated into fire which is
becoming the standard way that we
maintain information in at least in the
healthcare system and another
interesting paper this actually comes
from Oh chin which most most of you
familiar with HN in their build of epic
they have actually implemented tools
that help capture data around social
determinants of health I don't know if
some of our fellows who rotate at epic
and tell us more about it because I
pretty much know just just what I've
read in the paper plus I I know Rachel
Gould
who was the first author on it and being
able to capture at least have the
ability to capture social determinants
of health information and and finally
I'll close with something as some of you
probably saw last week the American
College of Physicians which is the
specialty Society for internal medicine
physicians there's a number of us in the
room who are members actually came out
with a major health policy actually
statement would be an understatement and
they they they came out with sexiest
supplement to their journal Annals of
internal medicine a plan to improve the
healthcare system everything from
financing to quality measurements and
there's actually two articles in this
supplement which is available open
access and of course we get annals of
internal medicine anyways in our library
but it they actually made it open access
so anyone can get to it from anywhere
and two of the articles are addressed
social determinants of health including
the article by Karen DeSalvo who
previously was the director of the
Office of National Coordinator for
health IT and now is the chief medical
officer of Google so it's gotten
attention that way so I think this is my
last slide and I'm gonna turn it over to
John so social determinants of health
but if you'd like generalize them as to
who has a transportation need is there a
housing issue is there food insecurity
is their ability to understand and
follow a care plan so if we say those
are the social determinants of health
where are they recorded in our medical
record who who really knows the answers
to those questions and how how timely
and accurate is that data there are
three challenges for for social
determinants of health right now first
one is alignment as as bill is saying
what's the taxonomy how do we record
them CMS has one standard other national
organizations are coming up with
competing standards that's that's just a
process and an alignment issue there's a
technology challenge how do we work on
the interfacing how do we bring that
data into the right ecosystem in a
particular electronic medical record
those two challenges are manageable
they're there they're normal the
pedestrian third challenge is trust so
that is the barrier in the
meals-on-wheels example we'll talk about
later there is somebody who has daily
exposure to a patient and their social
circumstances and the changes and they
have a relationship with that person
they are the best primary evidence
however there's no trust for that who is
that person
would we let them into epoch and make a
change in medical record and so that
third challenge is really a serious
barrier to being able to integrate
social determinants of health into
clinical information and be able to use
that to do segmentation and risk
stratification so this is this is where
the tie-in to blockchain and it will
hopefully explain what blockchain is and
then why that trust issue is so
paramount to the challenge of social
determinants of health and integrating
with healthcare and how blockchain could
possibly help address that so I think
the the first challenge is is to
demystify blockchain so I think if we if
we said we've wanted one takeaway from
here someone asks you what is watching
the simple answer is blockchain is just
a database so if you take that away
that's all you need to remember about
blockchain
however it's it's unique so typically a
database is at the center of an
organization it's at the center of a
medical record and because it contains
such crucial information it's usually
hidden behind firewalls and layers of
security and Trust so for you to get
access to the database you have to be
part of an organization that trusts you
they give you a login so
that they can authenticate you and then
they authorize you to do things and that
works because that organization has
control over everything and they can
build a firewall around it so so that's
the traditional database and we said
blockchain is also a database but what's
fundamentally different is it leverages
technology so that it no longer has to
rely on trust in fact everybody could
have a copy of that database because the
technology prohibits somebody from
gaining access to something that isn't
theirs but allows them to enter
transactions or information that's
relevant to the intersection of a member
and a provider care team so this this
has been used in financial places this
blockchain is is actually the solution
to a problem that that digital currency
was facing how do you manage a currency
that's not regulated by a bank or a
government you can't trust some dot-com
to say that that will give you money and
they'll manage a digital currency so the
idea of how to gain consensus how to
have a trusted database that nobody
owned was resolved in the creation of
Bitcoin so bought chain is a database
there are there are a couple of
distinguishing factors that explain why
it does not have to rely on trust and
why it's so secure but instead of hiding
it behind a firewall you could put it
out on the Internet
so those three principles are
decentralization distribution and
immutability so they're kind of jumbled
together we'll take them apart one at a
time in common language decentralized
and distributed can kind of be used
interchangeably but here we're going to
make a distinct difference so
decentralized means that there's no one
controlling organization credit cards
work because visa net controls those
transactions and interactions and people
enroll and if Pisa net trusts them then
they transact through that trusted
environment in a decentralized
environment there may be many groups
working to
so it could be a Hsu Moda
meals-on-wheels
Providence a care provider social
workers health coaches but none of them
are controlling the system there's no
one medical record that everybody is
logging into that everybody trusts we've
decentralized that across multiple
organizations one of the ways that they
protect against fraud or manipulation is
to distribute the database and so in in
this case it is a physical distribution
because it's so secure everybody could
have a copy and the advantage to having
multiple copies distributed across a
region across the world is that it makes
fraud very difficult to perpetrate so in
the case of social determinants of
health it's going to be more around
access to the data and being able to
make the right changes to that database
in this space of cryptocurrency
it's about guaranteeing that no one has
created a fraudulent version of those
transactions that you're trying to
operate yes
just like functioning yes so so the
question is around how do we know we can
trust this so the distribution means
that multiple people have a copy the the
challenge historically was how you gain
consensus so if everyone has a copy you
want the majority to be determined to be
right so if a single party tried to
create a fraudulent transaction the
majority would overwrite that and ignore
the fraudulent piece the challenge
historically had been is it
there was no mathematical technological
way to guarantee a true consensus
especially if somebody could fall off
the network for a little while and then
come back on and have to catch up you
could have multiple people claiming
different versions of the truth or
multiple truths over different times so
if your if your Bitcoin and the idea of
cryptocurrency mining all the
electricity that goes into mining is not
producing new bitcoins it's it's not
mining in a physical sense it is
literally proving that they've done some
work they've made it so hard what
they've done is they've made it hard to
make an entry into that distributed
database and it's it's made more
difficult the more people that are
participating to make fraud impossible
and so it's difficult to do an honest
transaction it's then impossible to do a
dishonest transaction that was the
original problem of proving consensus so
that we could trust that distributed
network and that was originally
associated with a lot of electricity
usage it was it hard means electricity
and took electricity to power the
computing cycles to to solve a puzzle to
guarantee that someone couldn't
fraudulently enter transactions since
since since bitcoin was invented there
are now ways of providing consensus that
don't depend on that
but that still allow multiple people to
have a copy but fraud not to be
perpetrated there's a nuts-and-bolts on
that that would be kind of fun to dive
into but you you're on the right track
so distributing copies is a key to being
able to trust and make sure that that's
not fraud so we have centralized
decentralized there are a number of
examples so visa net for example is
centralized there's one controlling
party but they've distributed nodes
across multiple locations real estate
land title is is in many cases
centralized and non distributed it's
often a paper book someplace so so
there's a model for Bitcoin which is
decentralized and distributed that was
unique as of its time so there are
copies of that database all over the
world and there is no one controlling
party that it takes how that works so
those two things alone aren't enough to
guarantee transaction integrity so the
third piece is the ledger so a ledger
could be a set of transactions like
credits and debits it could also be
vitals and diagnostic codes and chart
notes so it's just anything you would
put in the database and in a blockchain
they they take a bunch of transactions
and they group them together and they
call that a block so when that block is
filled they go on and create the next
block so so that on its own would not
provide enough security to guarantee
someone hadn't gone back and changed a
transaction or that we know who made
that transaction so it goes one step
further into an immutable ledger and so
it starts again with a set of
transactions and those transactions are
signed mathematically and that that
signature creates a unique fingerprint
for those transactions you the
fingerprint is is over 64 digits long
you can't change a single period in
those transactions without coming
with a completely different signature
for that so so that first block is
finished signed and its signature is the
very first thing in the next block and
so it proceeds to add more transactions
come up with another signature and now
that signature starts our third block so
you can kind of see how this chain of
blocks works together you could not
change a transaction upstream without
affecting its signature its signature
was written into the block that followed
it so everybody can easily check the
integrity do these transactions produce
the right fingerprint that takes
milliseconds to check and they can check
the entire chain so so that that's the
the origin of the blockchain NAM occur
so it guarantees that multiple parties
have a copy no one owns it and no one
can change it so maybe if those were the
components it might help just a little
bit to talk about how blockchain works
blockchain is a network and so as
individual if I'm transacting in Bitcoin
or I'm gonna send social return data
into the the network I log into my
computer I use my credentials to say I'm
me on my account that I've set up on my
own without an authority and when I
enter my data so the the vitals on a
particular person that that information
is encrypted and broadcast to the
network the network has a bunch of nodes
they were listening to create those
blocks they gather up a set of
transactions or for health information
entries and they mint a block they form
a consensus on who owns the right
version of that blockchain that that set
of the database and then that that new
block and the rest of the chain is
published back out to the rest of a
network so it's a think of it as a
peer-to-peer database in that regard
so in our space there are some
interesting challenges there's no way
you can delete something in a blockchain
everything is permanent and everybody
could have a copy of everything so
thinking about HIPAA and how we would
work around that in most of our
day-to-day environments when we encrypt
something we use one password to encrypt
it and the same password to decrypt it
and that that works for us but if we
have to send somebody a piece of
encrypted information we'd have to send
them that password in anyone who
intercepted it along the way could get
it so that would be inherently insecure
Bitcoin would have been cracked a long
time ago if that was what we were
leveraging so so the blockchain uses a
public key cryptography it's a two-sided
key I have a secret and I have a public
key and so I can sign something you know
that if you have my public key you can
guarantee I signed it if I have your
public key I can guarantee you sign to
something so when we talk about patient
security patient information that that
privacy is protected by a two-way key if
we talk about the integrity of somebody
outside of your health care system
outside of your medical record making an
entry you can guarantee through the
public key cryptography and the
architecture of the blockchain
that you know who made that entry you
can decide later if you believe their
input or not but there is no question as
to the origin and the authenticity of
that that source I don't think will
drill into some the compliance
implications but it's important when
we're talking about social determinance
of health healthcare information and a
technology for storing that to look at
the current environment so HIPAA has
portability as part of its prime
directive but most of its enforcement or
most of its emphasis has been around
privacy so looking at HIPAA the GD P R
from the EU the California Privacy
Protection Act and the 21st century
cures act evaluating new technology and
its ability to compete compliance with
some of those conflicting regulations is
a key piece and and I think there's an
excellent use case for blockchain being
able to thread a needle through all of
these so so we'll finish I think by by
putting a little more a little more
color around the meals-on-wheels
examples so meals and wheels this is
it's fascinating so as bill said it's a
it's a model where people are
subscribing to a service they may be
facing food insecurity or the inability
to prepare food for themselves meals on
wheels will prepare food at a central
kitchen and it has volunteer drivers go
out and deliver these so that the driver
is given a list of names and they walk
to these same people usually every week
maybe different people every day but
they've formed patterns and they they
cannot leave a meal if the person isn't
there the person is there they have
face-to-face contact they can see
changes in their behavior their eating
habits their disposition their social
determinants of health and if they don't
deliver a meal so much meals on wheels
Falls up falls up on that it's very
interesting because small things like a
customer being dropped from a list have
a huge impact on their health outcome
how are they eating if meals on wheels
is not providing the food that they
needed and sometimes it is not a core
issue of food insecurity or something
else it's the delivery got cancelled
because the steps are slippery and the
drivers can't come
so those things would never show up in
an annual wellness visit and and a
primary care provider that's seeing them
one point six times a year
doesn't have the frequency and the depth
of information so these volunteers have
fabulous insights into into each of
those social determinants but we don't
have a mechanism that would allow them
to go into medical records and make an
update because we don't trust all those
unknown entities and there's no
mechanism to delegate trust to social
service workers across all sorts of
different conveyors
so the idea around leveraging blockchain
to establish the veracity of an identity
to maintain a set of tightly controlled
and secure transactions that integrate
social determinants and healthcare and
that are available across organizational
boundaries right now if Moda went out
and gave meals-on-wheels and interface
to our systems we we might know
something but they know it just you
would have to create another system to
go integrate with meals on wheels
and Providence and Legacy and Kaiser and
it's an impossibility meals on wheels
can't build and interfaces to
proprietary systems so the the premise
that blockchain is a technology that
does not rely on trust that could bridge
a gap in social determinance of health
and help outcomes is is the premise that
we came up with out of the blockchain
adventure studio and that we're trying
to see where the conversation leads next
and Lynn has a microphone this
microphone up here is this gonna solve
all the world's problems yes so patient
identifiers today if we got a list of
patients from OHSU and we looked at at
our registry and then we looked at the
hospital's registry we have to do
matching today so at some point there's
a certain amount of patient information
that's required to match an identity and
once we've done that match we now know
the motor identifier and the OHSU
identifier and so we could we could look
for that going forwards the same thing
would happen if we extend this to social
services
they'll have name address date of birth
gender and that's typically enough with
a zip code to get a match and so that's
kind of a standard information
technology challenge of doing an initial
match and then maintaining a lookup
table for identifiers mutism
the blockchain would record you know
those particulars in the organization
that they're under and if that
organization had an identifier that
would be inside of the blockchain right
or we could do what most other advanced
countries do and have a national
identifiers but that would be too easy
and not politically feasible but you
know the impact the counter-arguments
the national identifiers is that there
are entities especially technology
companies that are really good actually
at matching people so if it it likely
would work an overwhelming majority of
times to use the kind of matching that
that h IES and stuff do now
um I was curious to know so let's say I
like you know I was receiving meals on
wheels and I've actually like Dunhill
something else before so like I was
receiving it and you know my information
was recorded help watching yes I'm
curious to know so I would have to like
give basically motor whoever my health
insurance was access to the key to be
able to other mechanisms where social
workers or other yeah that's that's uh
that's something we deal with outside of
healthcare when we agree to terms and
conditions on a free service we're kind
of trading our access to our information
for that service when we sign up for a
program it has a certain number of
benefits and and hopefully they're being
very explicit about it but that
acceptance of of that use of your
information it can be established
upfront and and so you can opt in you
can opt out for those that opt in we
could get that information if and and
what you'll see with things like the GDP
our general data privacy regulations I
can't remember the the the idea though
is that you can opt out at any time you
have the right to be forgotten and so
using the information on the blockchain
to record the current status of what
you've opted in for and yeah it's also
upfront getting getting acceptance to
those terms as part of membership in
certain plans
thank you very much what at out is very
interesting to me I have two questions
specifically to one the data that you so
traditionally blotching has been used
for financial transactions there was a
very
I guess standardized kind of data yeah
healthcare is you have multiple
different pieces informations with
various length and complexity how do you
incorporate that into the very structure
weight a blockchain is created and the
second question is how do is there any
plan to do anything with the contract
base block chains that's like a theorems
and things like that we come up with
yeah actually those two questions do fit
quite well together so even on a
blockchain like Bitcoin traditionally
it's being used to store transactions
debits and credits but there's also an
unstructured data field so people have
stored images they've stored other data
in a blockchain transaction so there's
no inherent limit or structure because
it's on a blockchain I just happens to
be expensive on something like Bitcoin
to record something I was in a
transaction another blockchain that's
also equipped with currencies etherium
etherium took the starting point which
is transactions and then it also added
smart contracts which are basically
programs they can say they can run
automatically if they see something
happen if they see an input or something
change they can execute code and so so
some of this could live in a set of
transactions some of this could leverage
a smart transaction I think in the case
of social torrents of health we're
really looking at this as a database
that could be shared across users who
don't have formal trust so we're not
looking to leverage some of the smart
contract capabilities of like an
aetherium but all those blockchains have
the ability to store an arbitrary data
structure the theorem is probably the
most likely launch point though from for
something like this oh thanks for thanks
for the talk was really good when you
said all the users would have a copy of
the database I mean that's kind of the
idea how does it work in this technology
that certain users don't have access to
kind of all the information and they
would have access to only what is
relevant how is it possible in this
technology
yeah my second question was in this
model who is going to pay for for this
okay really the question we chose first
so III probably I should have been more
clear everyone could have a copy of this
data so a note and when we looked at
that mesh distributed picture a node has
a copy of the database and so if if we
were doing a lot of work on that
blockchain we may have our own note so
that we have a current copy if we didn't
have our own note we could always
address any other nodes in the network
so it's a peer-to-peer database you
don't have to have your own copy your
interface could go to talk to somebody
else's you have the right to maintain a
copy and that's an advantage in the
space of cryptocurrency because it
prevents fraud here it's just a matter
of accessing the data in a more timely
manner so if everyone could have a copy
of that database whether they choose to
or not it's that public key cryptography
and leveraging also a symmetrical key so
that we know that the person who created
that data or the member that that data
represents is protected by a public key
and that way even though everybody has
that transaction they can't read it they
would need the opposite key to reverse
that encryption so everyone has a copy
of random numbers random looking numbers
that they couldn't do anything with
unless they have the right keys thank
you so the second part of your question
is who pays for it I think that's the
the challenge is that this is in a space
where it's predominately
disadvantaged populations perhaps
Medicaid or some parts of the country
where there's an outsize impact by
social determinants of health so you
know is their Medicaid program that's
funding this is there some sort of
capitated care model that is buying into
this that's that's a challenge there is
no incentive to go build this
infrastructure so there's a lot of talk
of social determinants in healthcare
there's a lot of individual
organizations looking to see how the
can engage but there's no there's no
funding source right now you know in
some sense that kind of mirrors the
question about health information
exchange hie
there really still isn't a business
model to give an OSU an incentive to
send its data to Kaiser I mean I suppose
now we have care everywhere which is
kind of part of epic but you know for
patients who come from different places
and things like that there aren't
financial incentives to send the data I
mean unless you sort of take a kind of
global perspective like oh well if
someone pays to get that data to this
place then in the healthcare system they
might not need to reorder tests or they
could you know be more efficient in how
they make diagnoses and treatments so
how how this would information would be
used it seems like it's intended to be
used at the point of care like by a
primary care provider so what would
happen if like the example he gave was
if meals on wheels were reported we
weren't able to bring this person a meal
because it was too slippery out like
have a hard time picturing if I for
example like called a provider and said
that my patient didn't get a lunch today
they would say so I guess what would be
talk about population health there's a
whole spectrum of care the the provider
might be the anchor and they might be
seeing that person one or two times a
year and they might be looking
systematically what does that patient
need it if they are having challenges
with disease management into chronic
conditions or social trends of health
ideally their provider network their
insurer is trying to get them into a
population health program a health
coaching program or maybe a disease
management program so those those parts
of the care continuum are designed for
more hands-on a day to day or week to
week interaction and so ideally we
find is a change in their social
determinants of health we're using that
information to segment a population
it's what kinds of needs there might be
and then just to risk stratify so build
a model identifying highest risk so we
know we're engaging with the right
people first so as those social
government to house would be used to
identify the right people for the right
intervention and then it's through a
care coordinator or a health coach that
we'd likely see that that interaction
take place you know I would just say it
I mean think you know I sort of talked
about the kind of upstream versus
downstream it's probably not efficient
to send the information to a primary
care physician that sounds so missed
their lunch yesterday but you know there
could be you know a population health
there could even be sort of population
level clinical decision support oh you
know mr. Jones has missed you know three
meals this week you know we should do
something about it you know and and
actually especially like in a capitated
health care plan where you know you're
you have some incentive to you know keep
people healthy or at least to keep them
from getting worse so knowing that kind
of information it's probably best not
not to go to the physician but there may
be others in the kind of social services
network that could benefit from that
information and and act on it that's a
good point in the example of someone
being diagnosed with diabetes and then a
prescription for insulin that's
expensive you know where that person
lives their economic situation their
housing security their their food
insecurity at some point the physician
should know if they're getting a
prescription for expensive medication
they may be choosing between food
today that's not in the medical so we
look at
I agree and it but it seems like
typically in terms of funding it seems
like typically what is done is that
information is geo coded into the
person's record based on which census
tract they lived in live in and then
that can be linked to census data for
example that's what I Chen did with
their advanced CDR and databases they
just had it geo coded so all of their
patient information links to information
from that person census tract which
seems like an easier and cheaper way to
do it so full disclosure my like
research areas and geocoding and use of
location so I guess I'm saying it's
possible that my belief and how you
could solve the same problems a little
bit self-serving but what would be the
advantage of doing it the blockchain way
instead of the more typical geo coding
level in terms of trying to to look at
the predictive value of models built on
census tract information and if we're
trying to identify like the top one or
top five percent proactively through
models what we're finding is that the
census tract is still too broad to be
able to identify and stratify patients
so getting social determine on an
individual basis to create a model that
has a higher predictive value is the
next step I think census track allows us
to understand populations and that's
very useful if we're looking at
individual interventions then then like
recording this primary data or acquiring
it through third party is essential
great so we have one and then one so I
in to me when I hear it trusts as a
major challenge first so using social
determinants of health I mean it would
it goes it would go beyond sort of data
privacy and data security to to some of
the really starting to references what
is done with that data and it and I
think that were it seems to me we're
still working out like
structures for that and that might be
way out of the scope of blockchain but
in but how in what ways to could
actually help support that for example
giving different levels of privacy or
the ability to retract information or
corrected or contested things like that
yeah one of the other organizations that
are GA and the organ enterprise
blockchain adventure studio was working
with was was an organization that was
literally tracking opt-in opt-out all
sorts of programs online so they're
creating a master registry what have you
opted into what if you opted out of and
what dates and what's effective so
blockchain is a permanent record you
can't change it so in this case if
someone opts in and we share it's a
piece of information they opt out later
and then there was a concern why did you
share this the nice thing about the
immutable ledger is that we can say on
this date there's absolutely a hun
percent sort of you know we know that we
were doing the right thing that it
changed later so so blockchain kind of
gives us a chain of custody for any
changes in what we have authorization to
do it allows us to monitor that on
multiple level so you can opt into one
program you can always opt out of a
different one and and all these privacy
rules are very very clear on the patient
always has the option to opt out and we
have to call it
I think there are different levels of
opting in so if you want to subscribe to
a plan and the organization has decided
that there's certain information that
has to be collected to administer that
plan if you want in you have to buy off
on that piece when we do something like
social determinants of health that is a
separate component so people can opt in
of a health coaching plan if they opt in
if they want health coaching we would
need extra information and so we have to
allow them to see what we're collecting
and we have to explicitly get their
permission to opt in and when they did
it but but we compared them together and
a lot of organizations have been doing
bulk registrations so they haven't been
collecting this before they say if
you're in this program we need you to
sign this to maintain membership so I
think especially with gdpr and some of
these other compliance pieces we're
gonna see like when you go to your
account before it's your address and
some of the things about you I think
you're going to start to see your your
terms and conditions and your and your
history of what you've your
information-sharing compliance a
question and a comment can you hear me
okay on this yeah first of all I work
with Oh chin I'm one of the co-authors
in the study you put up earlier about
and we do we are doing screening that is
integrated into the EHR so there is
there are screening tools so people can
ask at the point of care about the
social needs that patients might have so
my one question is what we're really
struggling with is at the point of care
you find out someone has a need what do
you do and so we've been working with
creating these social service or
collaborating with places that are
creating these social service resource
look Resource locators so we know where
there's resources but really wanting to
figure out ways to communicate with
those resources and like from the
point-of-care out and maybe there could
be bi-directional communication and
there's all these barriers and could
block Jane be something that works that
way that was part of the kind of our
original conversations was you know one
one block chain was focusing on the
patient and another related block she
was focusing on services and so then we
could see interactions between those
patients and those services or so
there's things like two one one where
you could type in an address and it
would tell you here all the social
services in your area if they were
working together but they're all these
individually maintained repositories you
know different provider groups are going
to maintain a list of social service
providers same same with population
health Edmodo and other organizations so
the idea of you know this goes back to
it'd be easy if the state just said here
we're gonna create a master Registry of
social services or we're gonna create a
master health information exchange for
social determinants of health so in the
absence of those two pieces we're
looking at how do you how do you do that
without trust and that's the blockchain
is not the simplest solution if we could
get a legislative agreement on the needs
and the format for for these systems the
state-run database would solve the
problem you're talking about in the
absence of that blockchain also could
provide a way of going back and forth
with the services and they could add
themselves and then the provider can to
say okay based on who they are I found a
match and I can decide if I want to
enroll or not one other quick thing I
just wanted to say as we have geocoded
the data at ochen and we've done some
looking though of people's reported
self-reported needs and the geocoded
census tract information and it doesn't
always match up so I think that although
like you were saying like the census
tract information is useful like there's
still some there's still some relevance
to really asking individual patients and
looking at other kinds of data I think
as well so we'll do one last well before
one last question for Jenna EXCI
question came in over the Twitter feed
so I always want to make sure we
incorporated that and it came from
someone who many of you know Deb
Woodcock presumably out there listening
xiexie wait phrased it as a sentence but
I'll turn it into a question because
blockchain does not depend on trust is
it a potential solution for sharing
social determinants health information
among electronic health record systems
which I think it is and that's part of
the advantage to this that it if people
had the proper authentication than
someone's sto H information that's
sitting off of blockchain
could be accessed either potentially
incorporated or queried if your system
didn't want to incorporate it so so it
could be incorporated but inherent if we
have a medical record and maybe we could
use that pic as an example care
everywhere care anywhere create links
those links are based on trust all those
organizations trust epic and its
management of those interchanges so we
don't need blockchain that is a trusted
in a sense it's a centralized database
even though it's distributed across
different health plans that connection
is done through epic and there's there's
trust there so so I want to make sure we
there's a principle called Occam's razor
and it's to use the simplest solution
possible for a given problem so for in
that example we could add in information
off the blockchain to that ecosystem but
we wouldn't have to use blockchain if
everyone's on a medical record that has
a common trust then that that is the
simplest solution so as Ojin and others
start to add Z codes or the prepare tool
or find that alignment then the
technology is there
so they trust each other the trials with
trust then goes back to who really knows
the primary evidence and if it's a
volunteer at meals-on-wheels how will
that get into the system and there is no
trust and it's that's that's the unique
challenge here is that the person who
really knows isn't trusted by the people
who need it so if we just had epic
keeping all of our information we could
trust UT Bachman anyways Jen last
question great talk they're two very
interesting areas and you talk a lot
about trust and blockchain is a great
means of securing data and you talked
about trusting the person on the
meals-on-wheels end but I think there's
a lot of lack of trust on the other end
too and patients trust
ding Moda right and and the insurance
company and Bill dr. Hirsch gave a great
example of we have these data that an
intervention comes out and the people
with the social determinants of health
lower their cost on the system that
their medical costs and the the converse
or the unstated underlying assumption
there is that people with high social
determinants of health needs are very
expensive and they have high medical
cost so now you have a system where the
people who have the least means and the
highest costs are getting flagged and
identified and the security of the data
is there but how do we trust modem
what's being done to trust how those
data are being used and how are those
data being used and and why should that
part be trusted that's a that's a good
question and probably a very nuanced one
so there are regulations in terms of
what you can do with with information
and how you're aggregating risk and
coming up with what's the right what's
the right price for a particular product
based on on history so there are all
sorts of examples where one extreme case
can make a very challenging situation
but there's legislation that you you
cannot single them out you can't do
carve outs in that in that regard in
terms of of care in especially when
we're talking about chronic conditions
of something like a NMFS or diabetes or
congestive heart failure with with
obstructive pulmonary disease those
people need care they're expensive to
the system and look at costs as a sign
that something's gone wrong so not only
is its cost something that that the
system is trying to manage it's also an
indication that patients not getting the
best care going to the emergency
department is 10 times more expensive
than going to primary care so part of
this involves people following the
intent of what they've asked for
permission to use that information for
and demonstrating that if we do have
this information we can find the right
intervention for the right people and
their outcome is better and their cost
is lower and it doesn't guarantee people
won't exploit that
but that is the that is the only way
forward to help those those people we
can't help them if we can't identify
them yeah I mean you know we just you
know that's where laws and regulations
come in you know so laws you know just
like there's laws now about covering
pre-existing conditions and and things
like that and so those obviously need to
be in place because because there is
actually a societal benefit for reducing
someone's downstream health care costs
you know if even though maybe the health
care organization you know or the
insurance company whatever you know may
have incentives that are not really
aligned with the patient and society at
that end but if you have laws and
regulations and can try to catch some of
these things upstream to do something
about it then presumably that will
provide those protections so anyways I
apologize that we've gone a little over
but this is great for us to hear your
input thanks a lot
[Applause]